when you make art from a truthful place
[Music]
people find out something about you
we're a team right yeah we need to find
a new way to deal with the money
customer of mine was short of cash okay
we got instead and where's your kitty
Nate was mentioning you having a cash
problem well my business is no business
of yours well not right now but I think
we might be able to help each other out
what am I supposed to paint
damn
that is ugly
so from now on as a contract out I
suggest they buy art
what the frig do you know about R this
classy Art Gallery run by this young
lady who take a reasonable cut for
herself and cut us a nice clean check
my five-year-old makes better paintings
that's the beauty of this you cretan
this thing that looks like a Smurf would
diarrhea can sell for a million bucks
and the IRS wouldn't bat and I
what's the oldest name
Bag Man
The Bag Man Are You The Bag Man tell me
about The Bag Man I would never say it's
a good
people it makes me feel dirty
oh
in our critic he wants to do a piece on
when I hear no it makes me want
something even more this thing's
supposed to be a front that means low
profile why do I even have to tell you
this is not good I knew that money
laundering was a crime but murder I'm
sorry we don't have any work from the
Batman available it is an extremely long
wait list of collectors everybody wants
one
come on
flee like laundry are you really
mansplending money laundering to me
[Music]